look I'm not saying to date idiots okay
again as women We're Not Gonna date
we're not going to be involved with men
that have nothing going for them now it
might just be a looks thing okay and if
you want to have a dynamic where you're
just dating a dumb idiot and that's a
type of menu date okay lead the
relationship have fun have a great time
okay but I'm assuming that you're you're
a half smart woman okay and if he's not
the type of guy you could if he's not
the type of boss he could work for that
you would have been out the door before
you had a kid
I'm assuming and and if you weren't you
got some self-reflection to do love
because you make some idiotic decisions